yes Indiana Jones is among the most
beloved of film franchises but that
doesn't mean the movies are without
their flaws we've all rolled our eyes at
the scene where Indy survives a nuclear
bomb by hiding in a refrigerator but
here's a rundown of some other less
obvious but still pretty dumb things
that the Indiana Jones movies asked its
viewers to ignore when Raiders of the
Lost Ark opens Indiana Jones is unfazed
by his colleague stories about ancient
mystical powers that could destroy
everyone seeking the Ark of the Covenant
by the end of the movie
once he's experienced a bunch of goes
for the power to melt Nazis faces off
he's forced to accept that there are
powers in the world well beyond his
understanding he even ends a movie by
warning the government agents that they
don't know what they're dealing with
[Music]
bureaucratic you don't know what they've
got their great character arc right
here's a problem while it came out three
years after Raiders Temple of Doom is
actually a prequel that takes place a
year earlier in that movie in distort
man's heart matter fee ripped from his
chest while still beating and personally
turns magic stones white ass by invoking
the name of Shiva despite bearing
witness of all that's Indiana Jones is
still a skeptic in the Last Crusade he's
very quick to dismiss stories about King
Arthur and the Holy Grail as bedtime
stories he's even still hanging on to
those cells when Crystal Skull rolls
around it's one thing to try and ensure
your carrots that can be relatable and
realistic when he's dealing with ancient
fantastical mysteries but for Indy to
simply ignore some of the most exciting
perplexing and incredibly real moments
of his life is just silly
after thrilling chases a couple of
failed rescue attempts and they'll
smarting the bad guys at every turn
throughout Raiders of the Lost Ark
Indiana Jones and Marion Ravenwood are
captured and forced to witness a hellish
moment when the bad guys open the ark as
the power of the ark is unleashed in
details Marion that they can't look at
it no matter what happens he's right -
in the midst of a cadre of Nazis being
burned alive by the wrath of God the
good guys are spared from its wrath so
how in the world did Indy know not to
look at the ark earlier in the film is
mentioned that the ark was hidden away
due to its immense power being too much
for mankind to handle but the cheat code
of just closing one's eyes came kind of
out of nowhere also we're not
complaining
but it does seem as it's a weird that
nobody else figured out that they
shouldn't look at the blinding light
that was melting everyone as it turns
out Indy was warned about this in a
scene that was cut from the final
version of the movie that might be a
good way for Indy to know but the
audience shot dozen it might seem like
we're picking on Raiders but in a movie
that's otherwise perfect the few floors
are really easy to spot
take for instance Indies trip on a Nazi
submarine the key word there is on not
in with the help of a friendly sea
captain in these cells his way into a
u-boat
to rescue Marion and defeat Belloc
jamming us up it just before it goes
underwater the film thing cuts to an
island where the villains plan to open
the Ark of the Covenant so how did us
soaking-wet Indy survive the trip
obviously he couldn't just cling to the
periscope and hold his breath for
hundreds of miles but from what we've
seen in the movie and even at the lead
scene that's exactly what happened it's
just a good thing nobody ever bothered
to lower the periscope for the entire
trip or else would have to deal with the
explanation that Indy was secretly the
lost king of Atlantis all this time when
symbol of doom opens Indiana Jones as
accompanied by a young child named one
lay who Jones refers to a short round
it's later revealed that the young
Chinese boy from Shanghai got busted
trying to pick the archaeologists pocket
and they eventually became friends
well opinions are split about shortround
it's undeniable that he provided some
comic relief and drove the getaway car
pulled stunts as daring as as mentor and
even broke in thee from a magic
mind-control trance by the end of the
film they both return to the small
Indian village as triumphant heroes
after that who knows the third movie
opens with absolutely no mention of
short round
there's not even a whisper of him nor is
he mentioned in Raiders of the Lost Ark
which came after temple of tune
phonological a short around has just
gone after the credits roll romantic
partners like Willy come and go for a
rugged and handsome bachelor like Jones
the young child that he took under his
wing and brought thousands of miles from
his home on numerous death-defying
adventures you think that at least stay
in search we might even be willing to
forgive some of crystal skulls more
egregious sins if in these successor
turns out to be key he Quan instead of
Shia LaBeouf there's a lot to be upset
about in Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
but the most important might just be
that a shifts the genre of the franchise
in the way that just doesn't work
there's nothing wrong with a good
science fiction story if
what you want to call this movie but for
it to come in the fourth installment of
a franchise rooted in pulpy fantastical
adventure after a nearly 20-year gap
just feels jarring and unnecessary the
movie ends of Jones and his cohorts
finding a collection of alien skeletons
with one missing head after returning
the infamous Crystal Skull the aliens
come to life and vacate earth in a
flying saucer
Indiana Jones as a guy who frequently
comes across he unknown in his pursuits
of ancient and mysterious artifacts but
Roswell aliens are a very different kind
of mysterious even if and especially if
they show up 20 years after he was
dealing with biblical goblets they feel
out of place in in this world of
historical legends and supernatural
treasures in short never switch to genre
in the fourth movie of a series check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]